c'est une véritable bombe sanitaire à
retardement qui risque d'exploser dans
les camps de migrants en grèce ce jeudi
le ministère grec des migrations a
décidé de placer en quarantaine le camp
de réfugiés de rides sauna pour 14 jours
où vivent de 1700 personnes
au moins 23 d'entre elles ont été
testées positives au cours aux navires
us à partir d'aujourd'hui
l'infrastructure et placé en isolement
sanitaire pour deux semaines
tous les accès aux camps sont restreints
et la nourriture sera livrée aux
résidents le camp de rides sauna est
l'un des 30 sites d'accueil de migrants
sur le territoire grec qui héberge au
total près de quarante mille personnes
la surpopulation rend extrêmement
difficile la prise de précautions
nécessaires tels que la distance
physique et une hygiène vigilante sur
place l'organisation internationale pour
les migrations tire la sonnette d'alarmé
tout le monde est en danger les migrants
et les réfugiés engrais sont sensibles
au virus
autant que la communauté grecque il est
essentiel que tout le monde y compris
les migrants et les réfugiés sur le
continent et les îles soit assurée d'un
accès égal aux services de santé y
compris la prévention le dépistage et le
traitement en particulier dans des
moments comme ceux-ci l'inclusion
immédiate de tous les migrants dans la
réponse nationale au coronavirus n'est
pas seulement une mesure humanitaire
mais essentielle à la politique de santé
publique en grèce après ces premiers cas
découverts aride sauna tous les regards
sont tournés vers le camp de moria sur
l'île de lesbos où vivent dix neuf mille
personnes l'inquiétude est grande pour
ce camp de migrants le plus important
d'europe
la menace de coronavirus sera encore
plus urgent de décongestionner les camps
sur les îles lau liem contribuer à ces
efforts avec la création de nouveaux
arrangements d'hébergement sur le
continent 121 une ong et plusieurs
médecins européens ont adressé une
lettre ouverte et une pétition
gouvernement hellénique pour réclamer
l'évacuation totale et immédiate des
camps de réfugiés sur toutes les îles
grecques